Civilizations have used the colors,
black and white in their stories to represent good and evil throughout human
history. The Bible tells us black is evil and white is good. On the first page.
In the beginning, there was only darkness. And then God said,
let there be lights.
And he saw that the light was good cultures across the world,
associate black with evil death and the devil and to white with purity life and
heaven.
So it's no surprise that a black cat means bad luck and angels were white.
Since film began in black and white,
the medium works well for black and white dualism with such a strong cultural
foundation.
Filmmakers could easily give cues about a character based on their blackness or
whiteness.
In the song.
The appeal of black and white symbolism is that it's easy to grasp the
distinction between two extremes with this binary.
There's literally no gray area starting with the great train robbery,
Western films and cereals used to the simplicity to their advantage.
Black and white hats are an easy way to tell who's the good guy and who's the
bad guy.
And this tradition continues in modern filmmaking where it seems like every
major franchise has incorporated the symbolism in some way in the same way that
black and white symbolism creates a simpler and clearer metaphor.
Black and white filmmaking creates a simpler and clearer image.
The black and white is often actually preferable to color,
especially in movies where movement and timing and atmosphere are more important
than pretty pictures or landscapes color can add too much information to a
scene.
The simplicity of black and white film making and black and white imagery makes
it an enticing tool for filmmakers, even while shooting in color,
despite the opportunity to use color modern directors like David Fincher and
Christopher Nolan often choose de-saturated pallets that look almost black and
white.
This choice adds a visual clarity to their scenes by creating a simpler image.
Desaturation is a trend that extends beyond just Fincher and Nolan.
It seems like whenever a filmmaker wants to convey realism, normality,
or a sense of familiarity, they choose a less colorful palette.
Many critics defend black and white filmmaking as superior Pierce.
Cinema. And in fact, I think parents almost ought to take kids and say, Hey,
look,
this is another way that movies used to be made in it's part of your cultural
heritage that I do.
Cultural heritage. Is he talking about the birth of a nation?
Very clearly exposes the racial undertones associated with black and white
symbolism. In this film,
a white actor uses blackface to show he's supposedly evil and to the KKK dress
and white to show. They are supposedly the heroes, not only was this film,
a massive commercial success and a huge influence on modern cinema,
but it also was partially responsible for the rebirth of the Klu Klux Klan.
The use of black and white symbolism implies a racial binary with whiteness
being inherently good and blackness being inherently evil,
but many filmmakers challenge that binary in two important ways first by
flipping the associations of black and white and second by injecting that
familiar binary with something else entirely.
So when does black and white not feel familiar?
I gotta get out of here.
The classic interpretation of black and white symbolism makes those colors feel,
but sometimes filmmakers exaggerate the colors to the point that they no longer
have that classic association with good evil, such a strong contrast.
Then it feels uncomfortable to the eye over doing black and white to the point
of unease has a long history in literature in Moby.
Dick Ishmael feels intimidated by the color of the whale saying it was the
whiteness of the whale that above all things appalls me for Melville.
There's an apparent terror to the uniformity of pure white objects that are
purely black and white are simple to a fault and feel a little suspicious after
all. How can something natural be that lacking of color?
Moby Dick is an early example of challenging.
Whether something white is automatically good and some movies use completely
white things in the exact same way.
Rabbits they're supposed to be cute on paper. They're adorable,
lovable animals. Have you ever gotten close to a rabbit?
You can tell in their eyes, they have the brain of, of like a sociopath.
You put a rabbit brain and a human body. You have Michael Myers,
the killer in American psycho.
The set designer purposefully made Bateman's apartment to white to make it
uneasy to the eye.
When the realtor repaints Paul Allen's apartment to completely white,
the color feels nauseated.
Don't make any trouble, please. I suggest you go.
In the same way that B's films, challenged black and white symbolism.
Other films shot in color challenge.
The suppose that familiarity of black and white images,
the first time most famous example is the wizard of Oz where Dorothy escapes the
Dole world of Kansas and falls into the colorful Oz,
even such an early color film,
portrayed black and white as a place that a character might not feel comfortable
in. Dorothy escapes the restrictions of black and white in favor of the colorful
world of possibilities in us.
But the film makes sure not to go too far with the metaphor because in the end,
Dorothy, happily returns home to her familiar black and white life.
But the satire Pleasantville use the same metaphor to full effect.
The film follows a brother and sister who gets trapped in a 1950 sitcom called
Pleasantville.
The fictional show echoes other popular sitcoms at the time that started a
typical American family and the town is ordinary to a fault. It has no toilets,
it never rains. And everybody always follows the rules.
It's a weird day to this place gives me the creeps as the brother and sister
teach the town to break their old fashioned moral codes.
The town slowly gains color in response, the mayor Outlaws it.
He literally bands colored people from entering certain establishments.
This film shows how black and white can feel to normal.
So put together that it feels unnatural.
It also shows how black and white represents a traditional past specifically a
past that excluded colorful thinking and literally colorful people.
It's a question of whether we want to hold onto those values that made this
place great. Another unsettling part of Pleasantville is the lack of color.
And it's casting the fact that there's no non-white residents adds to the
homogeneity of the town and to the residents within it.
We see the same creepy homogenity throughout American psycho,
where characters have identical business cards,
aside from a slightly different shade of white.
Look at that subtle off white coloring, a tasteful thickness on that.
Patrick Bateman obsesses.
Over white because he wants to conform not because he cares about purity
innocence or the idea of being good.
I see why you're still quit because I want to fit
in.
But the obsession with fitting perfectly into this mold brings Bateman no
satisfaction. In his case, white represents payments, derangement,
and obsession with power as a result of his hyper-masculine white elite
environment. Mid-summer I film shot almost entirely in the middle of the day.
Also disrupts classic notions of light and whiteness.
When the movie first came out,
critics praised it as a daylight horror film that subverted horror trucks by
dispelling the idea that darkness is the only way to create an unsettling tone.
In fact, the movies,
grim events feel more disturbing because they play out in broad daylight with
all the characters wearing white all,
but one main character suffers a violent end at the hands of a white Nordic
tribe that wears mostly all white worships light and holds an annual ritual to
ward off the black one.
Despite the fact that the film intentionally flips the horror genre on its head,
they kept one glaring horror trope. The black guy dies first.
It's an oversight that comes as a surprise in such an otherwise subversive film.
And it plays into racial tropes about black characters being more expendable,
but his death also plays into the cruelty of the white characters.
So the trope simultaneously reinforces data, black stereotypes and questions,
existing white stereotypes.
Ultimately when filmmakers disrupt classic notions of black and white,
they create new possibilities around to exactly the hero and the villain of the
story can be HBO's Watchman employs,
subversive black and white symbolism to critique our concept of heroism,
the main character, Angela ABAR sports, an all black outfit. At first,
it's unclear whether she's a villain or a hero.
She plays a cop that fights crime as part of a questionably good police force
full of superheroes,
which she quickly finds out is run by the KKK and her own crime fighting
grandfather was himself inspired by the black Western hero bass Reeves who wears
an all black outfit down to the black hat.
Perhaps the most impactful use of black and white and Watchman is the episode.
This extraordinary being in which Angela relives the memories of her
grandfather. The entire episode is shot in black and white.
And similarly to Pleasantville this episode denotes a serious shift in tone,
rather than a gleeful and familiar nod to the good old days.
This shifts to an entirely black and white palette is accompanied by intense
music and a horrific series of violent racial events.
This episode serves as a modern retelling of the birth of a nation put at
justice,
adopts his costume after being lynched with a black bag and new surround his
head,
fashions it into a Cape and becomes a dark figured hero that fights off KKK
members in white hoods,
put it justice takes the racial binary and literally fashions it into something
new Watchman perfectly captures an inversion of black and white symbolism and
imagery to disrupt and question the status quo.
So many filmmakers challenged the binary of black and white by using those
colors in non-traditional ways to contradict their association with good and
evil.
But films also have another way to challenge the binary of black and white.
Color.
Of course, colors have many different meanings themselves,
but when you used indirect contrast a black and white binary color can alarm
challenge and disrupt an image. Venture does prefer a monochromatic image,
but he actually does use color strategically to give visual cues in seven.
The only character wearing striking colors is John DOE.
His red jumpsuit stands out in scenes,
otherwise dominated by dark and earthy tones.
His colorful outfit creates tension in a world to that.
Previously had very little color. We immediately recognize him as an outsider,
giving his scenes a sense of unease that would not have been present.
Had he fit the overall color scheme and in the girl with the dragon tattoo,
the colorful tools in the background to create an ominous atmosphere because the
neon orange catches our eye. And we realize what those tools are for Fincher,
mostly uses neutral tones to create a pleasant image that LOLs the viewer into a
sense of normalcy. When he occasionally disrupts that normalcy with color,
the effect alerts,
the viewer of characters that threatened the visual status quo Fincher plays on
our comfort and familiarity with black and white imagery to create visual drama
and fear within his scenes.
It's so effective because color has often been used to represent the foreign
entity alien Dorothy's world is quite literally disrupted by color in the form
of the land of hos colors association with foreign or even alien landscapes is a
common trope compare Marvel film set on earth to the one sentence space
filmmakers understand that color is often associated with something unfamiliar.
Annihilation takes this unfamiliarity to the extreme in this film color is not
just unfamiliar. It's terrifying.
The central antagonism in the film is represented visually by intense color.
The landscapes within the shimmer are lit by an unnatural rainbow refraction.
And it actually mutates by making things impossibly, coloring lignin.
Tumors.
With this disruption, going down to the molecular level,
contrast the shimmer with the scenes outside of it.
And they look just like Fincher's films, mostly grazing whites.
The shimmer works as an antagonism because it plays on our discomfort with
color. It represents an alien change that makes us uneasy.
The film depicts the foreboding infection of color into an otherwise color of
this world.
These films reinforced the idea that black and white is natural and comfortable
color. Only disrupts the image in some way.
You and me tofu.
We don't do lollipops and rainbows because we know those are pretty colors.
They just hide what the world really is.
But doesn't that sell color short,
many black filmmakers embrace color in their films and reject the tradition of
black and white early cinema developed lighting techniques for white faces
within black and white color schemes.
But those white centric techniques were developed at the expense of darker skin
tones.
When comparing the lighting of black faces in black and white films with modern
films like Moonlight and black clansmen, it's clear that color lights,
black faces better.
Some also reject black and white for symbolic reasons for some black and white
films represent a time they were excluded or marginalized,
which explains why many black filmmakers actually use more color to denote
events in the past.
Sorry to bother you perfectly summarizes what black and white movies can't do.
It's a complete reversal of movies like the birth of a nation instead of a white
people, pretending to be black. It's about black people pretending to be white.
And it reverses the idea that color feels uncomfortable and black and white
feels natural.
You know, 35% of men who wear pink are more likely to start a franchise.
As Cassius gains wealth and status.
He moves to an apartment that looks exactly like Patrick,
Bateman's completely lacking in color,
but there is one colorful item that stands out the photo of his father,
which changes as he sells out,
showing his father's disapproval of the de-saturated life.
Cassius has chosen for him.
It's one thing to take the promotion, but now you are a full-out scab.
In this film color represents authenticity and staying true to your identity.
It makes sense that black filmmakers have an affinity for color,
both aesthetically and thematically,
black and white symbolism and film have their place at the movies and black and
white does create beautiful images, but it has its limitations.
Not only does this paradigm simplify our thinking and literally simplify the
film image,
but that simplification has historically been at the expense of people,
not a part of the status quo, but with colorful filmmaking,
it's not so easy to villainize some and to worship others.
So I am grateful for film shot in color because in the end it's not also black
and white
color is an excellent visual tool to illustrate the complexity, depth,
and humanity of life films like annihilation to this marvelously by using color
to demonstrate that nature is not only in chanting Lee, beautiful,
but also dangerously complex and full of patterns.
It's no wonder that nature documentaries like planet earth and blue planet are
shot in high definition with saturated colors,
the documentary nature's mathematics actually explores the core ideas that
annihilation is based on by using mathematics to understand nature's inherent
patterns. And with curiosity, stream's newly expanded library.
You can watch nature's mathematics and thousands of other documentary titles
that use vibrant color to understand nature's mysteries CuriosityStream is a
subscription-based video service with big budget non-fiction films,
but they've also partnered with Nebula, a creator owned streaming service.
That's built by content creators, just like me.
Nebulous subscriptions are automatically included with an annual subscription to
curiosity stream. So you get the best of both worlds.
You can gain access to high quality documentary films while still supporting
independent creatives who are ly on your support to continue producing amazing
work. Plus you gain access to an extra.
Now you see at video ad free Nebula also features some awesome videos from my
fellow content creators. One of my favorites is how to music,
which teaches you the sound production process behind some of music's most
iconic bands and artists. If you want to try both curiosity, stream and Nebula,
go to curiosity,
stream.com/n Y S I and enter the promo code N Y S I when prompted during
the signup process, thanks to curiosity stream for sponsoring and thanks to you,
our patrons for your support. If you want to support our work directly,
join our Patriot. Thanks for watching.